what is great marketing what does it
take to
to to reveal the the pain and the joy of
a thing okay
it all starts at the beginning
and let me give you i'm gonna give you a
couple of different ways of looking at
it okay and again we're going to might
go a little long here
so
um
just stay tuned it yeah so the first
thing is the beginning let's start at
the beginning
in the early part of my career you know
like general magic and phillips and what
have you
and especially when i was you know a
teenager when i was like doing making my
own chips and stuff like that i really
worried about just putting cool things
together
i'm like that when i put those two cool
things together as an engineer you go
that's cool
and then i would talk to the other
friends who might be geeks too and they
go yeah that's cool
because we knew the bits
so we put them together and that's a new
way of doing it you're like wow
that's all what
it's not why
why are you doing this we know what
we're doing but we don't know why we're
doing it because we're not articulating
for ourselves because it's just
something we're like putting it together
like yeah that's cool because
because we think we're solving some
problem we have but we're not really
articulating it so what normally happens
and this happens because we invest in so
many companies around the world you have
these brilliant engineers designers
scientists researchers they put together
these
these whats
and then
they develop it develop it develop it
and then at the end they call in
marketing and say now tell a story about
this
and let's get it out to the world okay
what happens then is marketing is like
well why do why do people need this tell
us why people need it
and so they create a story around this
product
but the product was born out of what's
not wise
and so they start telling marketing
starts telling a story and it turns out
to be a fictional story usually they say
oh this is going to do these things
the product comes in is delivered and it
falls flat on its face
because the marketing doesn't match the
product because they weren't both
created at the beginning together
right there are what's when you create a
product but there's a lot more y's and
the y's help inform the whats and the
whys also inform the marketing
so at the
that's
what you mean deeply at we should start
at the beginning so
the designer should be also the marketer
the engineer should be the marketer
exactly stop impressing the geek next to
you what is the superpower you're
bringing or the pain you're killing for
the you're you're the end customer
right now let's get let's contrast that
think about a movie
a movie starts with a treatment it has
an audience that says the audience
here's the characters here's the
storyline the plot here's the here's the
here's the arc of the story right it
pulls that all out
then there's a script that's written
and that script is then produced and
then you add all the flourishes and what
have you music and graphics and what
have you right and then it comes out and
then there's the marketing of the movie
and that story was created at the
beginning
what you need to do if you're going to
do a great product is create that
treatment for your product and i call
that the press release
do the press release
like the treatment who's the audience
what what features do you have what
pains are you solving for people have
the virus of doubt there to remind them
what pains they have and why you're
solving them the price all of those
things and you use that
as the bar
the measuring stick for what you do
during development because what happens
that along the route you know this
oh we're not going to be able to get
that feature done on time
throw that one overboard we got to hit
the we have to hit the date oh
we're not sure this product's right yet
add another feature
add another fee feature creep
right
if you don't have that story you know
you're going to tell at the beginning
you don't have that bar
right
and then at the end you don't know when
you're done if you don't have that
source so you can actually look at that
press release
you might you know you you change it
over time um that draft but then when
you're done you know the what's and the
whys you have all the things the
audience and everything and then you can
give that to marketing and say
well marketing's been along the way
let's be clear but then everybody's in
sync and that's when you can tell a
cohesive non-fictional story about and
the product delivers on that story or
hopefully over delivers on that story
so
in the drafting from the beginning to
the end of the press release what does a
successful team look like who's part of
the draft is it engineers designers
what what's the purpose of a marketing
department in a company small let's say
a small company but more than two people
okay so
uh from where does the why come from
should it always come from the designer
or should there be a marketing person
that
yeah steps in and asked the question so
i'll just keep asking random questions
i know these are great questions okay
so
because you're just like i'm like i
can't wait to tell you the answer yeah
um so it's in the book as well
but you have to separate out the various
functions of marketing
when
that's what i thought i was like
marketing's marketing you know when i
was and and it's really not there's so
many disciplines just like in
engineering mechanical electrical
software and even software it's you know
use cloud services firmware applications
marketing has that much diversity as
well
okay and you have to honor that
and so
there is marketing communications like
pr press press there is um
social marketing there is a marketing
creative
right there's marketing activation
um
but there's another thing that also
comes out and people
uh
confuse it with marketing which is
called product marketing or product
management
and product management or product
marketing is the voice of the customer
they're the person
who sits there and listens to what's
going on and the competition in the
marketplace
understanding the needs and those pains
of the customer and they're representing
them in every single meeting so things
don't get off track
right
so that
um and they're creating the messages
not the marketing what happens is
there's messages that product marketing
creates like those are the deep messages
like
we need to save 20 of energy let's say
right and then marketing turns that into
something that's with creative and
everything
and brings that message across maybe it
doesn't say that but it comes maybe
visually or some other way
so product management does that and
and and and holds that press release
along the route and making sure that
we're tracking and then also marketing
is tracking with that press release to
make sure they're not telling a
fictional story right because they can
also add extra adjectives or something
and then the product can't deliver that
it's like no no no no it keeps everybody
getting to be grounded to the press
release to the raw right to the customer
needs yeah right because they're always
representing the customer so you have to
have a product manager typically that's
the founder
right in the beginning
and then over time you hire a product
management team
to then really
you know watch over this the whole way
and they are talking to customer support
they're talking to engineering they're
talking to design they're talking to
sales and marketing and they are always
in the mix and it's the hardest thing to
hire for oh yeah so it's they have this
very important job of developing and
maintaining the why
exactly why is it the hardest to hire
for because you have to understand you
first nobody reports to you
right
you so you're alone and you have to
build great ties with all of these
different these different functions
you have to understand what they do have
be empathetic with what they do and you
have to get have to project
the customers empathy or empathy for the
customer to them and tell them why and
why this customer needs this why this
doesn't work and so that they learn more
they're not just doing but they learn
about the customer's point of view and
sit in there and stand in their shoes to
be able to then make better decisions on
the engineering details or the
operational details customer support
details so they understand
the ev if they're not the customer that
it's intended for they start to live
through and through their eyes and see
through their eyes of that customer so
they make better decisions and there's
probably
fascinating beautiful
tensions between that and sort of the
the the engineers oh that's cool sort of
the
you know developing the what uh exactly
and which makes it an extra hard job i'm
sure exactly
you